on voit maintenant parler être des
jeunes sportifs qui vont marquer cette
année 2020 pour connaître ses futures
pépites nous recevrons sur ce plateau
gregory canal est journaliste sur tv 78
bonsoir grégory basso mickaël alors il y
en a bien sûr des dizaines à suivre mais
vous en avez sélectionné 5
on commence votre top 5 par du basket
retenez bien son nom victor webb anyama
le basketteur originaire des yvelines
joue actuellement à nanterre il a 15 ans
et mesure tenez vous bien de mettre 18
c'est un beau bébé comme on dit dans le
genre effectivement il l'a pas encore ça
atteint sa taille est définitive le
sportif a débuté au chesnay versailles
victor un profil qui lui permet d'être
surclassé depuis ses débuts il a
participé à l'euro avec les bleus et les
a emmenés jusqu'en finale ces
statistiques 9 points 9 points 6 rebonds
5,3 contre le basketteur également fait
ses débuts en pro contre les italiens de
brescia en eurocup en eurocup et il a
joué 32 secondes
il ya également des pistards de l'équipe
de france dans votre liste on la connaît
depuis un petit moment mathilde de gros
la piste ordre de 20 ans qui s'entraîne
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
elle bat tous les records de précocité
elle est notamment double championne
d'europe du keirin et elle sera l'une
des têtes d'affiché de la délégation
française aux jo de tokyo est cette
année
autre pépite du cyclisme sur piste
sébastien vigier d'origine estonienne
il s'entraîne également vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines il
a 22 ans le sportif a déjà remporté
l'argent en vitesse par équipes aux
championnats du monde en 2019 et le
bronze à les deux années précédentes
sébastien viger qui a également remporté
le bronze en 2018 en vitesse
individuelle ils devraient faire les
jeux olympiques de tokyo cette année une
espoir a également dans le triathlon une
triathlète à suivre dans les yvelines
cassandre beaugrand la sportive de 22 en
lice ainsi à poissy a déjà été
championne de france courte distance
elle est également championne de france
d'europe et du monde en relais mixte
avec l'équipe de france de triathlon qui
a cendres a déjà participé aux jo de rio
en 2016 elle a été à 8e du classement
mondial en 2019 et sera probablement cet
été aux jo de tokyo
enfin on termine par un pilote
automobile jimmy elias le guyancourt toi
et tes
sept ans et 10 mois le plus jeune
champion de l'histoire du sport
automobile sur mini kart il est
aujourd'hui chez l'équipe tony kart il
vient de resigner à 11 ans aujourd'hui
il continue à enchaîner les bonnes
performances avec son équipe et fait
partie des pilotes les plus suivies en
europe
le pilote participera cette année au
championnat à mini 60 géré par la fia la
fédération internationale automobile qui
regroupera les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux il va notamment faire des
courses en italie on sait que c'est un
très beau berceau au berceau de du
circuit automobile mondial l'italie
merci à grégory pour toutes ces
précisions